foreign
thank you
very soon
um
okay it smells amazing
[Music]
um
on the agenda
having regards experience
as soon as they become a rash in the
name arise throughout the museum
any interests
uh that occasion is 0.10 Seafood
Millions
it's uh with us as the original
application we're from 1601 and 4924 is
determined by the southeast planning
committee this is a ineffective
unexpective application
uh supporting these
publicly completely booked and there is
it wasn't correctly natural plans and
there was recommendations for Korean
subjects of the conditions
details of Section 8 of this report and
Lisa Greenwood is to present to us for
this
Hey sir
okay
um as such as you said this application
has been called to be excited by the
community as it seeks to amend addition
to of Planning Commission reference 1601
492 full which is the approved plans
commission 1601 492 sought permission
for a proposed replacement dwelling to
re-establish the three fronted geography
parade
the application site is outside of the
defined separate battery in normal
circumstances there would be a policy
objection to this proposal
however
as the development was considered to be
about standing and in a physics design
incorporating features that will protect
the structure out flubbing it was
considered an extension to policy may be
made in accordance with the now
superseded paragraph 55 of the national
planning policy framework
The Proposal originally sought to
provide for a single three-bedroom
flooding within the northwest corner of
the site
a new access would be formed in the
Northeast and a small formal Garden
would be formed at the West with the
remainder of the site of scrub land
following the grant of Planning
Commission the applicant sought to
discharge a number of accounting
conditions attached to the noses
including a condition regarding the
proposed materials and Battery
treatments
notwithstanding those the applicant had
not built the dwelling in accordance
with the approved plans
I just
yeah different sort to rectify this by
buying the retrospective planning
admission for the game as it is built
this application was refused as it was
opposed also related to the design
and the palette materials of the
approved dwelling would result in
development of limited architectural
Merit
today is a religion of this refuse
application and follows pre-application
discussions with officers The Proposal
now seeks to retain the extensive
glazing metal screeds which are operable
software climbing and stability
[Music]
on the North
you can't do it yourself
Squidward is it possible for you to
enlarge the Clarence so that we can see
them
or the Innovations
if you go to full screen
all right
[Applause]
even though some bar on the top please
yeah
the very top where you see the X and if
you go left of the X right on the very
top and if you click on that three large
one
you can see where this x go left of the
X and if you click on work sort of like
two squares it's actually a nice picture
[Music]
there's a presentation
with it
do you want me to take control
chairman just remember the public it's
important that he can't hear the members
and then speak
the reason
s
if you could just approved taking
trouble either
because I'm just not I'm not in silence
you still have the president
that's
it yeah
thank you
okay
so the glazing above the atrium on the
North elevation which is here has been
omitted
and some changes are proposed to the
fenestration on the Northern boundary to
account for internal configurations that
will be easiest to show you that these
windows
have been changed here
there are two windows there and now
these four windows are smaller
the composer also includes details of
the boundary treatment
which consists of a 1.2 High post of our
fence 1.5 meter high brick piers and 1.5
meter high wooden gates
it should be noted that the site's
access and driveway are not shown to be
in the same place as the approved plan
associated with planning application
which talks to amend the location of the
access to further sound
the local planning Authority has spoken
with the agent for the applicant who is
happy for a condition to be attached to
any forthcoming commission to ensure
that the vehicle access is in accordance
with the planning permission
whilst it has acknowledge that
alliterations have been made to the
northern elevation
considered to be so significant to harm
the overall character of the area and
justify the withholding of commission
subject to the information of conditions
it is recommended that Planning
Commission is now granted
wow
speaking
yeah Lisa can you hear us
had you finished I saw January yes
like who Mendes
um
who is an old member for this one
opinion yeah right what remembers
anything to try from there yes I've read
the report chair and I'm aware of the
history of all of this and I've met him
before and obviously there's been a lot
of teachers at the offices and to me
depends on their support sums it up and
I'll support the approval chair and I
would recommend approval of this
application
does this travel all the alterations as
it's built now yes yeah depleted yes yes
about moving the drive
or not
there's a very there's a lot of history
on this side as you're probably aware
they came in with an amputation in 19
2019 to change the access for the
original approval now the access has
been built in accordance with that
commission so we are happy with any
access is and we've got we have a
condition attached to the decision
notice that make sure that access is
and when this application is received
foreign
[Music]
um but I've been in contact with the
agent for the accident through the whole
process
well generally only reason I asked that
question answers because you know we've
got an approved scheme which the yeah
it's gone ahead and changed and I I just
wanted you to understand when they
decided to come to the council so in
other words when they
so I
answers really understand when we came
forward because you know if
so you know I'm not I'm not happy about
process I think it's quite shame because
if the officer flicks back through to
what I presume is the staircase
on the on the middle of the milk
elevation
there's one that's showing
list
where the fence stations are they've
been architecture is actually not if we
had glass Atrium on the top yeah yeah
when I mean we've got what's approved
and
now propose which is I presumably built
I mean the one to the right to me looks
completely out of balance the
architectural Focus one of the roof Labs
you know the topic of what I pursue is
either a cereal or some kind of a tree I
mean
what's actually being built I think it
looks anything near the numbers
and I think that's great shame because
this is one of the most in particular
designs that I think that this community
ever looked is
um
the fenestrations have changed quite
dramatically I'm not going to use
therefore but we're being improved
there's only two now but they're much
smaller which means the whole require
aspect in my arm changes dramatically
and of course there will be in time
when the development
so when they've decided just to have
those for those three of those the two
large ones okay I'd like to think that
that's actually reflects on when they
made their plan
es personally
that design that comes to the community
on architecture merits alone with a lot
of things
um
this applicant has been dealing with the
council since 16 trying to
get this sorted out he's made
alterations yes but during coven he had
a job getting materials
and their counselor flew through a say
no but he has had a rough time he didn't
start with 16 but then came and gained
19 and now we're in 23.
thank you okay any other members
yes
what we're actually looking at is this
visible from the road or from the city
yeah it is yeah
yes
I would just save you just to buy the
clouds in perhaps or the council outline
I don't recall during code before
there's only
instructions I think they became very
expensive so if that happens
big windows and that's why it has all
the time
yeah
nobody else any other comments in that
case we have a proposal by cancer
services
the green officer recommendation to
approve somebody happy with that
yeah Gates
that case it is approved
during the writing six any other items
of business that the chairman of the
committee decides are virgin I have none
side will close the meeting yeah
19.
[Music]